mientras los nuevos casos de coronavirus
siguen en aumento en la india algunos
centros de vacunación siguen vacíos
debido a la falta de vacunas en muchos
de los estados del país lo que está
haciendo imposible concertar citas de
acción y calcedonia gátchina aquí no
tenemos vacunas desde ayer estamos
pidiendo a la gente que vuelva más tarde
porque no tenemos vacunas málaga del
equipo china velo el día a pesar de ser
el mayor productor mundial de vacunas
indias se ha quedado sin dosis con el
país contando en torno a 4 mil muertes
diarias por kobe 19 la demanda es enorme
en medio de la escasez del estado de
maharashtra anunció la suspensión de la
vacunación para menores de 45 años que
había comenzado el primero de mayo en el
resto del país los ciudadanos entre los
18 y 44 años deben concertar una cita en
línea una norma que excluye a una buena
parte de la población especialmente en
las zonas rurales
[Música]
creo que por eso buena parte de la
población india incluso por encima de
los 35 años no han sido vacunados porque
básicamente no tienen acceso a una
computadora y a un buen internet
y aquellos como yo que no tenemos un
celular que vamos a hacer así falta una
vacunación puerta a puerta disponible
para todos debido a la alta mortalidad
los crematorios están colapsados un
hecho supuestamente relacionado con la
aparición de 100 cadáveres en el río
ganges el pasado martes un suceso que
preocupa a las autoridades sanitarias
por el momento india vacunado a menos
del 3 por ciento de su población 38
millones de personas de un total de más
de 1300 millones